sie hören herr frank den bayerischen
gesundheitsminister und hören auch
dessen warnungen sehr differenziert aber
hören dessen warnungen hören auch wie er
zu einer neuen lieferung von impfstoff
gegen pocken jetzt steht hören die
warnung die er aus spricht richtung
herbst was neue corona mutanten angeht
und wir sprechen hier über das impfen
stellen sie fest oder glauben sie dass
ihre patientin schafft sich noch einmal
aufraffen kann zum impfen gegen die neue
corona mutante gegen
neue pocken variante also ich befürchte
dass durch corona ein massiver
vertrauensverlust in die medizin droht
weil wir einfach die leute haben das
geld kriegen dass immer mehr mit weil
wir hier eigentlich das was wir haben
wir haben gute wissenschaft in
deutschland wir haben gute standards
weil die gerissen werden weil die nicht
zu wort kommen wir haben wissenschaftler
die sehr differenziert damit umgehen die
uns die auf patienten schützen indem sie
fortschritte möglich machen aber den
schaden versuchen zu minimieren und wir
haben hier uns angewöhnt über wirtschaft
sagen alle experten waren jetzt
undifferenziert alle wissenschaftler ist
geil doch bei corona nur noch panik
panik panik und läutet die die da sehr
differenziert waren wurden nicht
zugelassen na ja und da muss ich auch
mal ich mein es geht doch nicht dass ich
neue medikamente ständig zu lassen und
die gefahren übersee hat übrigens unser
gesundheitsminister auch nach oder eine
unheilvolle geschichte finde ich vertrat
sie schüttelt den kopf über herrn frank
ich würde gerne herausfinden
was wir in dieser generation jetzt
erlebt haben generationen corona herr
frank schildert das aus seiner
perspektive jetzt merken wir in dieser
zeit in dieser corona zeit krankheit
gehört irgendwie auch zum leben dazu
nachdem wir alle zeit irgendwie dachten
menschen haben das alles unter kontrolle
wir können so viel ist wir können
medizinische wunder vollbringen und
jetzt erleben wir es gibt sachen die
größer sind als wir gegen die wir uns
ganz schwer werden können mit denen wir
leben müssen
das wussten schon immer das leben ist
endlich und krankheit ist etwas
natürliches was uns alle betrifft die
einen mehr die anderen weniger die die
denen es besser geht finanziell die sich
besser schützen können besser ernähren
können die haben eine höhere
lebenserwartung die die in unserer
gesellschaft
ausgegrenzt abgehängt werden die wenige
gesehen werden die haben eine geringere
lebenserwartung und nochmal zu dem
impfen also ich
wir haben unsere wohnungslosen patienten
informiert und da war auch ein hoher
bedarf sie haben gesagt wann werden wir
geimpft das war gar nicht so einfach
weil wir nämlich dorthin gegangen sind
wo die menschen leben in der teestube
und so also nicht irgendein impfzentrum
und ich glaube wir haben insgesamt 300
400 menschen geimpft kein einziger hatte
nebenwirkungen kein einziger hat eine
komplikation also das muss ich auch mal
betonen natürlich müssen wir jetzt
kritisch selbst kritisch schauen und ja
es muss jetzt auch auf den tisch kommen
wie hoch ist denn die rate der
nebenwirkungen wie viele menschen haben
darunter gelitten aber man muss auf der
anderen seite bitte auch das darf kein
keine dogmatische diskussion sein
sondern das muss eine wissenschaftlich
reflektierte diskussion aber die tage
darf hinein nicht unterstellen dass sie
das alles nur aus welchen gründen auch
immer gemacht haben das so geht das
nicht nur ja sie vermischen sich dinge
miteinander es wird doch gerade nicht
überprüft das ist doch der punkt ist
dass wir das doch jetzt auch über brüder
wurden doch egal wer macht das denn
derjenige der das macht der hamas wird
diskreditiert das sagte die charité als
staatstragend sein und kann kritik an
der impfung nicht publizieren also wohin
wir werden wir werden hoffentlich im
herbst einen an mutationen von corona
angepassten impfstoff bekommen und ich
bin davon überzeugt dass ich eine große
mehrheit der bevölkerung erneut so dass
das ist der punkt auf den wollte ich
noch mal mit herrn trabert ihn aus weil
er ja auch sagt weil sie uns so schön
aus der praxis schilder dass sie eben
dorthin gegangen sind zu den menschen
dass sie nicht erwartet haben dass sich
die menschen die zu ihnen kommen in die
einrichtungen in den einrichtungen sind
das die sich selber bewegen dass die in
den impfzentren gehen sie sind zu denen
gegangen haben dort geimpft würden die
das noch mal machen lassen im herbst
wenn sie dieses angebot wieder bieten
natürlich
gefragt worden wir haben mit johnson
johnson geimpft dann jesus das reicht
nicht bei montech und dann sind die
menschen zu uns gekommen haben gesagt
wann werden wir denn jetzt wieder
geimpft ja also da ist ein hohes
bewusstsein eine hohe sensibilität aber
was auch dahinter steht um auch mal von
dem impfen wegzukommen wir müssen
vielmehr in die stadtteile in soziale
brennpunkte gehen und generell
gesundheitsangebote machen und mehr auf
prävention und gesundheitsförderung
setzen das ist etwas ganz elementares
und das kommt absolut zu kurz und es
braucht die kontinuität des kontaktes um
vertrauen zu schaffen und das bedeutet
natürlich auch ehrlich zu sein auch über
gefahren zu informieren aber die nähe zu
den menschen die erlaubt vieles was
nämlich in der praxis in der distanz und
die botschaft ist angekommen heute abend
hat gar war hab ich ihre leben
botschaftern zählen die runde würden sie
sich im herbst noch mal impfen lassen
werden sie dabei vermittelt sagt ganz
große mehrheit der deutschen der trabert
macht dieselben erfahrungen da gehen sie
davon aus dass ich auch nein natürlich
nicht
diese diskussion gefällt mir gerade
überhaupt nicht wollte ja weil wir das
gut rüber weil wir kommt vollkommen an
einer wissenschaftlichen soliden debatte
vorbei reden ich muss sauber ermitteln
wer profitiert davon wer wird geschadet
volants ich es zu wo ist die grundlage
der zulassung und all das ist nicht
geschehen und ich glaube dass sehr sehr
viele menschen das langsam auch sehen
vielleicht nicht wirklich zu geben aber
im bekanntenkreis sehen dass es denen
nicht gut gehen geht reden sie mal mit
bestattungs- und also sie raten raten
jetzt an der stelle tatsächlich allen ab
diese empfehlung anzunehmen und sich
alle radler ist dringend sich nochmal
die eu-verordnung bedingte zulassung zu
lesen und jeder politiker muss dann
erkennen dass die zulassung gestoppt
werden muss und die sicherheitsfragen
geklärt werden weil sie ist das ganze
verschwörung gegen irgendjemand oder was
einmal hören sie mir eigentlich nicht so
ich auch ich höre ich hab so ich
argument mal sachlich fachlich ich sage
ich nein das genau die gegenposition ein
und aus und emotional ja natürlich es
gibt diese können bei einander dass wir
bei einer doch ich kann gemeint habe
sondern die sicherheits die
sicherheitsfragen sind eminent und es
steht in fünf nur 7 der verordnung dass
daneben evaluiert werden muss und es
wird nicht getan sagt dies meldeten die
heute ist eigentlich die menschen werden
das für sich entscheiden wir als politik
sind gefordert neue moderne angepasste
impfstoffe bereit zu stellen die
menschen werden die diesem jahr und 10
jahren in 20 jahren immer wieder
annehmen das virus ist in der welt und
wird uns bis zum ende des lebens
begleiten und wir werden wahrscheinlich
jedes jahr wie bei der grippe impfung
einen angepassten impfstoff für corona
bekommen und das ist auch gut so worüber
wir glaube ich nicht mehr diskutieren
sollten ist eine impfpflicht auf allen
ebenen ich denke das ist auch aus der
axis heraus nicht mehr notwendig weil
politisch sehr schneller strich ist das
eigentlich am ende verzeichnete
pflegekräfte setzen sich dafür ein dass
das erfragen
wir sind am ende dieser sendung ich
möchte einmal in der einsatz antwort von
ihnen allen hören wo stehen wir mit
blick auf dieses neuartige affen
pockenvirus eigentlich in einer woche in
einem monat werden wir über 100 fälle
über 1000 fälle reden oder gar nicht
mehr darüber herbert ich habe keine
ahnung ich bin da nicht kompetent genug
herr frank es ist ein völlig für die
geführte gesundheitspolitik an völlig
nebensächliches thema vermittelt
also ich glaube dass wir in einigen
wochen klarheit haben und das dann
darüber nicht mehr gesprochen werden
muss weil sich herausstellt dass die
gefahr nicht ergebnis